reinforcements are heading to the front
line for what could be the final battle
for Tripoli militia allied to the
internationally recognized government
moved heavy weapons and fighters south
to the outskirts of the capital we them
had you brigade support forces are on
our way to the capital Tripoli we are on
our way and God willing we will be
victorious after hours forces are also
reinforcing their front lines each side
has foreign help Turkey is offered to
send troops in support of the Tripoli
government while heft art has soldiers
for hire there are a thousand new
Russian mercenaries deployed to Tripoli
according to two US officials in one
source in Moscow quoted in Bloomberg
News Sudanese and chatty and mercenaries
all assembling on the front lines for
what they're calling the final push so
it's increasingly likely that turkey
will deploy something to help defend
Tripoli if needed by the GNA with the
threat of escalation looming Italy's
foreign minister Luigi DeMaio met with
both sides on Tuesday holding talks with
Faisal Siraj in Tripoli and then with
half dar in the eastern city of rajma
inviting him to Rome for further talks
the UN is calling for the two the rival
governments and international backers to
agree to a political solution we
continue to call for de-escalation and
for active support by all Libyans and
international actors engaged in Libya to
find a peaceful and political solution
to end the conflict and by addressing
its underlying causes I think it's
important that the international
community as a whole
rally around the efforts of the Libyan
people of course and also the efforts of
the Secretary General's representative
mr. Saleh main tried to find a political
solution this conflict analysts say is
becoming less and less about Libya with
international actors pulling the strings
and flooding the battlefield
Andrew Chappell al Jazeera